Welcome, iOS developers.
For today's Quick Tip, I want to
show you this cool new drawing
app I just made, Pressure Draw.
It is a simple drawing
program with one little twist.
If I touch the
screen lightly, it
makes a thin line, like this.
But if I press
harder on the screen,
it makes a thicker
line, like this.
But wait a second, iPhones
don't have pressure
sensitive screens, do they?
So how did I do this?
Did Apple give me a
top secret prototype
iPhone with a pressure
sensitive screen?
No, no.
They didn't do that.
Why would they even-- no.
The answer is that
I'm taking advantage
of a new UITouch property
in iOS 8 called majorRadius.
You can think of majorRadius
as basically a measurement
of the size of the touch
that the screen receives.
I'm using it here to
approximate touch pressure
because, for human fingertips,
they tend to squish
and the touch circle gets
larger the harder you
press against things.
Note that this doesn't
work in the simulator
or if you have metallic fingers.
Sorry, Iron Man.
But for the rest of us,
it does work, kind of.
The problem that
I'm running into
is that the granularity
is pretty crude right now.
The smallest radius I
get is this 25.52429.
Then it goes from
there to like 38.29.
And then 51 point something.
I can get to some higher numbers
if I touch the entire phone
with my palm.
But that's kind of it.
For a single finger,
there's no real variation
in between these
numbers, which is weird
because these super precise
floats kind of suggest
there should be, right?
So if I turn off my little bit
of LERPing between major radius
sizes-- yes, LERPing is a thing.
Google it-- you can see that the
jumps in between my brush size
are actually pretty abrupt.
So in practice, I'm not
sure I would use this
for a real drawing program.
Sorry, Pressure Draw.
You will never see
the light of day.
So where could you use it?
Well, you could certainly use
it for nonessential UI polish
tweaks.
Do you have a particle
effect that goes off
when the user presses a button?
Well, you could use
the majorRadius value
to determine just how many
particles you shoot off.
Whoo-- that was
a lot of dollars.
Or you could change the volume
of the sound that accompanies
the effect, or both.
I kind of wonder if you could
use this as a poor man's force
touch.
This is a UI
pattern that Apple's
looking to establish
on the Apple watch.
And maybe this is sort
of a jerry-rigged way
to apply this to
devices that don't have
pressure sensitive screens.
But frankly, I'm not
sure about this one, yet.
That's why you got a
big question mark here.
I would say proceed
with caution.
Honestly, I think the
best use of majorRadius
might be not to
detect touch pressure,
but instead to distinguish big,
ungainly fingers from thinner,
elegant fingers.
Here's the thing.
In games in
particular, if you look
at a lot of the good, really
high quality stuff out there
today on touchscreen
devices, they
will cheat to make
sure their players are
doing the right thing.
Here's a favorite
example of mine.
This is the game 10000000,
which you should totally
buy if you haven't yet.
It's on the App Store
and the Play Store.
So check this out.
Here you can see
I'm moving my piece
to a point where I'm
really only about 30%
towards making a valid move.
But the game kind of nudges
me a little bit forward so
that my piece settles in a
place that makes a match.
And it works the other way, too.
Here I've overshot my move
by about like 70%, right?
But once again, the game
is cheating a little bit,
and settling my move back into a
place that makes a valid match.
Isn't that brilliant?
I'll answer that for you.
Yes, yes it is.
This game is, nearly
invisibly to me,
doing what it can to make me
feel like I am a good player.
And it's these kind of design
decisions that can make
the difference between a game
that feels right and a game
that doesn't.
So tying this back
in to majorRadius,
say you've got a game with
a bunch of elements densely
packed onto the screen,
maybe a grid based puzzler
or a hex-based strategy
game, you can help out
your players by looking
at where they touched
on the screen, and the
size of their touch,
and then using a little logic to
guess at what game element they
really meant to click on.
So even if I am playing your
game with my big fat thumb,
I can still touch all
of the right elements.
Anyway, those are just
a couple random ideas.
I've asked around here.
And so far, we're only using
majorRadius in one place.
It's basically a
testing only feature
where we put up a little
indicator that shows where
our testers touched on screen.
And we're using majorRadius to
decide how large of a circle
to draw.
But if you end up using it in
your code, please let me know.
I am dying to find
out what you did.
You can put it in
the comments below.
majorRadius appears
to be supported
on any device that runs iOS
8 back to the iPhone 4S.
So there you go.
Thanks, again, to Dave
Oster on the Google News
team for the tip.
But what about you?
Do have a tip that would
make for a good Quick Tip?
Send it in.
You can email me at
the address here.
If we use it on the air, I will
send you a t-shirt, or maybe
a top secret iPhone
prototype with a pressure
sensitive screen, but
most likely the teacher.
Anyway, thanks
again for watching.
As always, click here to see
more videos from Route 85,
our show for iOS developers.
I will see you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]